before we go any further I want to tell
everyone that this episode is being shot
live with GoPros our floor director jen
is actually wearing a GoPro on her chest
to capture all of the action so no
pressure Adam just a few extra camera
today but you got good news to report
this just came out last night and sales
are going great yeah cells are
incredible on we did the the big force
friday opening a disney store down in
san francisco so they opened at 1201 and
there was a line going around the block
right and we went down there the line
and ask everybody what they're looking
for and a lot of people said like the
BBA droid that you're making like the
sphero bb-8 droid so it's sold out right
right now it's sold out on both Disney
com our website most of the in stores
that we found that opened already we
know that apple will be getting their
shipment of this for the Apple stores on
the 10th so right when they reach that
for whatever they announced on the 9th
they will also have varied roles so how
did you come up with the idea of a
robotic sphere so the sphere actually
came up we came up with about five years
ago me and my co-founder we wanted to
make something that was like
indestructible super cool robot
something you may have never seen before
and we wanted to change the way people
see robots we see him as like these
utilitarian things that just do
something for you and we're like we want
one that's fun it's your friend it's
something different so tell me about Bob
Bob Iger what kind of input has he given
you how did he get involved yeah so last
summer we did the Disney techstars
accelerator its accelerated program for
startups like ours and we had met with
Bob Iger we had our like 15 minute
meeting with him and it was just it was
a match made in heaven he really he
really soaked into what we were doing he
saw that we were trying to like embrace
robotics in a different way in an
entertainment type of way and so after
that he was like I want to become your
full-time mentor so should take take a
take a moment to show us how it works
here sure and tell me about the process
of developing the BBA that worked so
this has been pretty crazy process I
mean ask anybody making a hardware
product in 10 months that has to be on
the shelves is really challenging and
especially one that has to go through
this much work and this much approval
just because you know we really really
wanted to focus in like this is the
droid like if you watch the movie you'll
know this one's very realistic I just
have it controlled through bluetooth low
energy on my smartphone right so I can
like drive it around
and you can kind of look at us he can
drive around he can patrol on his own
and do all the messages that we saw
before but what's really cool is he's
also a real robot so you can program
this and kids can learn to program so
financially what does it mean to be part
of the star wars franchise I mean
financially when once we started like we
knew we were going to make this bb-8
droid it became very obvious that we're
going to need a little bit more
investment to make this product right
because we have to buy everything up
ahead of time so just financially we got
a 45 million dollar investment right
before making this just so we could
build enough of these but you're gonna
make a lot of money on it we've already
just weave out sold out done anything we
could have imagined